У цьому розділі ми дослідимо,
як квантові та класичні комп'ютери
працюють разом, щоб вирішити одне з найважливіших завдань
у науці — точне оцінювання енергії молекул та матеріалів
Досягти цього можна
за допомогою quantum circuit,
щоб генерувати базисні стани-зразки,
які потім постобробляються
і діагоналізуються за допомогою ряду алгоритмів
з цієї сімейки методів,
як-от SQV, SKG — і для них існує цілий курс
на платформі IBM Quantum,
присвячений цим та суміжним методам
Для наших цілей у цьому відео ми
обмежимось коротким поясненням
Незалежно від того, чи використовуєш ти SQV або SKG,
твоя мета — знайти власні вектори
та власні значення гамільтонової матриці
Ця матриця може описувати енергію фізичної
або хімічної системи, але той самий підхід
може застосовуватись до багатьох інших типів задач,
наприклад до логістики
Іноді ці матриці надзвичайно великі,
тому зменшення розмірності
матриці зі збереженням важливих
характеристик основного стану
може бути надзвичайно цінним — саме це і є метою SQV
Ми використовуємо квантовий комп'ютер для генерації корисного підпростору —
такого, що містить основний стан
Тоді ми можемо проєктувати нашу гамільтонову матрицю
на цей підпростір, що залишає нас
з невеликою матрицею, яку буде
набагато простіше діагоналізувати
за допомогою класичних високопродуктивних обчислень
Ми робимо це, підготувавши пробний квантовий стан,
який часто називають ансатцом,
і виконуємо вимірювання для сампування цього ансатцу
у обчислювальному базисі — це дає нам
зразковий підпростір в обчислювальному базисі
Але що насправді хочеться знайти —
це справжній основний стан
Що, якщо наш зразковий підпростір не містив
усіх необхідних компонент?
Якщо вибрати кращий ансатц,
можна отримати кращу оцінку основного стану
Це підводить нас до вибіркового
квантового уявлення та діагоналізації, або SKUD
У SKUD ми починаємо з ансатцу,
як і раніше, але потім застосовуємо quantum gates, що наближають
еволюцію фізичної системи в часі
Можна показати, що за певних припущень
це гарантує перекриття між еволюцією в часі
ансатцу та справжнім основним станом
Обидва ці алгоритми починають з величезної
гамільтонової матриці і працюють дещо по-різному,
але в обох випадках квантова частина алгоритму видає
підпростір, що дозволяє нам стиснути матрицю,
зберігаючи при цьому ключові характеристики основного стану
Де ж класичні високопродуктивні обчислення
вступають у гру для найбільших гамільтоніанів
та найточніших оцінок основного стану?
Навіть ці проєктовані матриці можуть бути досить великими,
тому залучення потужніших класичних обчислювальних можливостей
може допомогти нам не тільки
отримати кращі результати,
але й розв'язувати більші задачі
Щоб зв'язати все докупи,
ми можемо представити вибіркові алгоритми
як поєднання різних моделей програмування
на наборі гетерогенних ресурсів
Наприклад, ми можемо представити наш алгоритм
як робочий потік задач, де матимемо задачу
підготовки quantum circuit, що перекривається
з нашим цільовим станом, за якою слідує задача
транспіляції, яка потребує лише класичних ресурсів
Далі виконуватиметься задача,
що використовує примітиви для запуску quantum circuit
на квантовому ресурсі,
а потім матимемо задачу постобробки, яка сама собою
може бути паралельним алгоритмом діагоналізації,
що виконується на кількох вузлах
Крім того, можна запускати
один із цих алгоритмів багато разів,
варіюючи ансатц,
або запускати їх повністю паралельно
з різними параметрами
А тепер давай зведемо все разом на прикладі SKUD
у коді. Ось усі наші файли задач,
а ось усі наші файли для відправки
У задачі маппінгу ми підготовлюємо circuits.
На кроці оптимізації запускаємо circuit найкращим чином.
У задачі виконання сампуємо бітові рядки
зі стану, підготовленого нашим
ISA circuit.
Те, що ми отримуємо з попереднього кроку,
використовується для постобробки.
Тепер ми готові відправити наш
робочий потік SQV.
Як видно, все виконується послідовно
із залежностями — зачекаємо
на результати і перевіримо вихідні файли.
Ось відкритий файл кроку оптимізації,
де міститься наш ISA circuit.
І нарешті перевіримо нашу кількість
ітерацій.
З розкладу.
Ось і все — коротка демонстрація робочого потоку SKUD
Весь код буде доступний у текстовому розділі
або в описі нижче
Ось і все — ми розглянули кілька
концепцій та прикладів, які допоможуть тобі розпочати роботу
з управління складними гібридними програмами. Звісно,
якщо тобі це подобається — це лише поверхневий огляд
того, що можна зробити із поєднанням квантових
та класичних ресурсів. Щоб дізнатись більше,
перегляньте документацію та навчальні матеріали
на платформі IBM Quantum,
і обов'язково переглянь ресурси, зазначені в текстовому розділі
або в описі, для більш детальних матеріалів
і програмного забезпечення. Дякуємо за перегляд!
Так.